[Musique]
nous allons faire aujourd'hui une salade
vitaminé à base de carottes et d'orange
ce qui vous mettra du soleil dans
l'assiette on commence par éplucher 300
g de carottes et on les coupe en
tranches assez fine pour être le plus
léger possible si cuisson à l'eau avec
un peu d'ail et d'huile d'olive
on va faire des petits bouillons pour
démarre un petit peu poussé puis après
on baisse le feu pour que sa cuisse
apple donc une quinzaine de minutes au
bout de 15 minutes
on vérifie quelles sont tendres avec la
pointe du couteau si elles sont tendres
pour les égoutte et ont fait réduire le
jus de cuisson qui restent et pendant le
sac hui on en profite pour que les unes
oranges à vif
il ne faut garder que la pulpe pour
profiter au maximum des vitamines
donc vous voyez là on a tous et albédo
qu'on va enlever ainsi que le zehst un
très épais koné va largement et on suit
la forme de laurence jusqu'en bas pour
assaisonner c'est tout aussi simple on
récupère le jus d'orange et on y ajoute
un peu de sel de la fleur d'oranger et
de la cannelle si jamais vous trouvé ça
un peu léger pas de problème la chef a
tout prévu
alors cette recette que je vous propose
en salade aujourd'hui vous pouvez la
faire aussi en place dans ce cas là vous
pouvez accompagner votre vos carottes
orange avec des coquilles saint jacques
ou un filet de poulet cuit à la vapeur
par exemple ou juste grillé comme ça ça
vous fait un plat complet ça y est c'est
près il n'ya plus qu'à dresser présenter
les carottes et l' orange sur quelques
feuilles de salade sucrine saupoudrez de
cumin et ajouter du jus de citron
rien de mieux pour vous donner un bon
coup de fouet face au froid de l'hiver
[Musique]